the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right welcome everybody really
pleased to see you all here today or
will be the first of a nine lecture
course I call signal processing on
databases and this is a really special
day for me because this sort of
represents a big step in a set of
technology that I've been working on for
a couple of decades and you know really
been working intensely onthe last three
or four years and this is the first
course on what we hope will be a
technology that will become very widely
used it is a completely unique course on
a completely unique technology so I want
to thank you for being the guinea pigs
of this course it's hard enough just
doing a new course on an existing topic
doing a new course on a on a novel topic
is quite a challenge so we're gonna be
trying a few different things here
you're gonna be certain topics covered
from more than one angle and we'll see
which one sort of make the most sense
for you the first thing I'd like to do
is talk a little bit about the title of
the course which is a little bit
different title the signal processing on
databases which is not two phrases
signal processing and databases that are
usually connected together very often
and so signal processing as we all know
is here at Lincoln labs one of the most
core things that we do in terms of a
technology it's almost difficult to
imagine a technology that's more core to
what we do the only thing I could think
of was systems engineering
maybe but signal processing is really at
the heart of what we do mathematically
signal processing really the heart of
that is detection theory how do you find
things given sets of data how do you you
know eliminate things you're not looking
for
find the things that you are looking for
and then mathematically the heart of
detection theory is linear algebra and
so just to show of hands how many people
have had a linear algebra course in
there see that's that's really awesome
see at Lincoln that's probably this one
a few place in the world where I was
pretty unanimous you know there's not
too many places where that's the case
and so this technology is really
designed for you because it really
assumes a foundation in linear algebra
and that's not as common as you might
think and so people who haven't had
linear algebra it's much harder for them
to take advantage of the ideas that
we're going to talk about so signal
processing detection theory when you're
algebra that's sort of kind of the root
of that first phrase the second phrase
databases when we think of databases we
think of typically you know maybe things
that you do searching on the web text
you know maybe other things like like
like that which is not necessarily
consistent with the mathematics that we
think about when we think about signal
processing detection theory and linear
algebra we naturally go on to like real
numbers matrices those types of things
so what we're really doing here is we're
connecting that mathematics with sort of
a whole new branch of data words and
strings and relationships and so that's
kind of the really novel piece of it and
its really the core idea that we're
bringing here's we're gonna bring all
that machinery that we know so well and
we're gonna try and apply it to this new
area which is becoming increasingly
important for us so that's the
explanation of the title that's how we
pick the title we could have there's
other titles and so so I just want to
spend a little time on that an enormous
number of people have contributed to
this work this this is a list of of the
people that I could remember at the time
that I typed the slide but no doubt I
have forgotten so
important and so I apologize for that
but you know certainly these people and
and the whole team have been very
instrumental in allowing this technology
to move to move forward here so this is
going to be the outline for this
particular lecture and there's going to
be a rhythm to most of these lectures
which is going there's going to be a
lecture which is going to be PowerPoint
I apologize we all see plenty of
PowerPoint mainly to introduce ideas and
then there will be sort of a demo which
will go through code that is actually
available in your ello grid accounts now
and some of that code will even be part
of homework assignments if you so choose
to do the homework assignments and so
that's going to be the flavor we'll do
the slides we'll take a short break and
then we'll do the the examples and talk
about them so let me talk about some of
the kinds of and I stole the slide let
me talk about some of the kinds of data
that the technology that we're going to
be talking about today really really
enables it allows us to deal with data
that has to deal with relationships
relationships you can particularly as
those represented by graphs so for
example you might have vehicle tracks
those represent relationships between
locations you know a car goes from one
place to another that's a relationship
between those locations
another is social networks you know
everyone wants to know who their friends
are how many friends they are who their
friends and friends are those types of
things so that's another type of set of
relationship again very textual and
oriented very much oriented towards
words and not numbers another area is
cyber networks very apropos topic
that people are you know at least
everyone is impacted by and many people
are doing work on which is you know
relationships between computers
communication between web servers those
types of things and again that is a very
important area for us just to give you
sort of a big picture here like well why
am I even here why do I care about this
what are the things that we can do I'm
gonna kind of walk through an example of
some of the things that we have used
this technology for that have been very
exciting for us and so trying and we'll
have examples like that throughout the
course you know how you can actually use
is how this has had really a real impact
and so the first one we want to talk
about is is some work we've done in the
cyber domain so here's an example of a
data set which is a graph that is a web
traffic and so if we see here this is
the source IPS so you can imagine these
are the computers that are on the inside
of some domain and then these are the
destination IPS all the web servers that
they hit are the green ones around here
this is sometimes referred to in graph
theory is a bipartite graph it's
basically two separate sets of vertices
that talk to each other but have no at
least in this data set we are not
recording any connections within within
the sets and then hopefully you can see
here these faint blue lines here that
are the actual connections that show you
you know which which of these computers
are connecting to which of these
computers there's obviously a lot of
data web traffic data there's an
enormous amount of it this shows 90
minutes of data and you know and in this
particular case there was actually a
malicious activity that you know we were
looking to it to detect in this data set
so one of the biggest challenges that
you have in any data set like this is
data representation and you know
sometimes in database parlance this
is called the schema so how you
represent your data is usually if you
can figure that out you're almost
halfway to solving the problem and so
given that in this case we wanted to use
graph techniques we discovered that our
data almost always doesn't come to us in
a nicely form form graph and so we have
to go through a lot of steps here and so
one thing you'll see is with this
technology is that it's almost always
pop a part of a pipeline from from raw
data to conditioning the raw data to
inserting it into a database to doing
analytics to doing queries and other
types of things you're always really
going to be using a pipeline and you're
going to be wanting to use different
technology tools for different stages in
the pipeline we're not in any way trying
to suggest that the technologies we're
talking about they are the only pieces
it's an important piece the technologies
we're talking about but they're not the
only pieces and you're always really
functioning in the context of a pipeline
so this just shows kind of the
technology stack that we will be
leveraging that we typically leverage in
those types of things ultimately our
goal is to get up here to these graph
analytics one of the things we'll talk
about most is courses the high level
languages that allow you to essentially
do graph analytics very easily and
bridge between the databases themselves
and a high performance computing that
you will need so again not only do you
have a pipeline of software and data you
have a pipeline or stack of technology
so when you're addressing problems like
this usually you're starting in one
place but you will almost always when
you build a system work out and deal
with these other types of things all
right so that's sort of just a quick
overview an example and I don't expect
any of you know it's probably just kind
of the person examples probably raise
more questions well how do you really do
this so now I'm gonna sort of took a bit
of a right turn here and really talk
about what like what the course is about
ok and I'm gonna actually talk about the
course a little bit of
a big picture and I always felt that
every course should should tell you why
that course is the most important course
you will ever take in your career you
know I think every single course you can
come up with an argument for that but
people don't say so I'm gonna tell you
why you know this course is the most
important course you will ever take of
course every course is the most
important course we take but I'm gonna
tell you why this one is so stepping way
back we're all part of MIT here at MIT
has a formula for success MIT is the
number one science and engineering
University on earth we can actually by
any reasonable measure that is true and
in fact by the people who track this
it's it's true by a lot you know and so
you know it's a real honor to be
associated with this organization to be
a donor ization that it's at its zenith
and mit has has had this incredible run
of success over the last 60 years
because fundamentally they recognized
the formula for making discoveries is a
combination of theory and experiment
bringing those two together and as an
organization we've actually organized
ourselves mit is organized around this
formula in that we have theory and
experiment and theory is the academic
part of the the mission that's that's
run out of departments typically it
involves mathematics this is a place I
mean everyone here raised their hands to
linear algebra and I can go to any part
of MIT and be and that that will be true
we probably have the highest
mathematical literacy of any
organization on earth and that's a very
powerful powerful capability the
mathematics that we use they become
manifest or real typically in the forms
of algorithms and our algorithms become
real in the form of software likewise on
the experimental side you know that's
the research that we conduct mit is
actually has large laboratories
laboratories that are fully peered with
the departments that is actually quite a
unique
thing for an academic institution to
have laboratories and laboratory heads
that are you know right up there and
with with the department heads and how
their positions Lincoln being the
largest of them csail the Media Lab
there's there's a number of them so we
have this thing the focus of research of
course is measurement which is data
which often gets reduced to bytes and so
often implementing this MIT formula
comes down to marrying software and
bytes together in a computer that's
that's sort of where we bring these two
ideas together and so we're gonna be
talking a lot about that implementing
software bringing bytes together and
analyze them together that's where these
two things come together and I think
that's really really important now
what's the tool we use what's what's the
machine that we use to bring these
together its computer alright and
nowadays computers have gotten a little
bit more complicated than the way we
used to think about them we used to
think about them typically as a von
Neumann machine which means you had data
in operations
you know bytes and software and the
bytes go into a part of the computer
they could operate on they they come out
and that model is still true at the at a
high level but but the computers we tend
to deal with now are much much much more
complicated so on the left is a standard
parallel computer almost every computer
you use today looks like this you have
processors you have memory you have some
kind of persistent storage you have a
network connecting them together and
these form a very complicated what we
call memory hierarchy it begins with
registers here at the top caches local
memory remote memory and then storage
and these are the units that go between
them and there's a lot of implications
of this part of this hierarchy in terms
of what what things are you know
bandwidth goes up as you go this way
latency goes down programmability
generally goes up the closer you are you
don't have to worry about things and
likewise the capacity of data goes down
as you go traverse this way in a
hierarchy so all modern computers use
that you use are these von Neumann
architectures with the
multi-level memory hierarchy and
fundamentally the thing you have to know
is that this this this architecture
selects the algorithms you use if
algorithms are not going to run well in
this architecture you probably don't
implement them so one has to be very
much aware of one's algorithms respect
to this architecture because if you pick
algorithms that aren't going to run well
in this architecture it's going to be
very very difficult the goal of this
course is to teach you techniques that
will allow you to get your work done
faster and so this is a rather
complicated drawing here but this shows
given a problem that you want to solve
if you implement it in software using a
variety of techniques you know how with
the performance of those techniques is
so in a certain sense you could view
this is the volume of code that you have
write to write to solve a problem and we
have implementing the program and C as a
reference point so as you move over here
and you do things like in assembly or
Java MapReduce you end up writing more
code you move over here and do things
like in C++ or Java or MATLAB you write
less code and this shows you the
relative performance again as you do
things in lower level environments like
assembly you can get more performance
and as you do things in higher level
environments like MATLAB you get your
less performance and this is a fairly
general trade-off space here we add
parallel programming models here of
which there's many we have direct memory
access we have message passing we have a
manager worker style or MapReduce style
we have a whole different styles of
programming here we're gonna want to try
and be here we're gonna want to do
things that take less effort and
delivery more performance and so we are
going to be mostly focusing on MATLAB in
this class and a technology we call
defer amel to describe that more later
but this is a software combination that
allows you to get
relatively good performance at
significantly reduced effort and that's
really the only thing we're doing in
this course we're just saying if you're
doing these types of problems there's a
right tool for the job or there are
right tools for the job and if you use
the right tool for the job
it will take you less time to get the
job done and we're gonna try and teach
you about these tools and how they
actually work now a little bit of bait
and switch here we call all the course
signal processing databases but we're
gonna get two databases at the very end
unfortunately to disappoint you all and
the reason is because databases are good
for one type of problem but it's often
the at the very end of the game where
you really need to work with databases
so to understand we have a variety of
different ways we can solve problems
with algorithms okay we can solve our
problems just using a single computer's
memory we can solve our problems using a
mold of the memory on multiple computers
we can solve our problems using using
disk or storage or even with many disks
okay and as we go this way we can do
more and more and more data but one of
the things that really matters and it
kind of goes back to that to the other
chart there is well when I'm working
with this data what is the chunk size
how were the blocks that I need to get
the data and if I need to get the data
in very very small chunks well then
obviously having the data in memory is
going to be the most efficient thing I
can do I want to just get one one record
out of many records then that's the most
efficient having the data in memory
likewise so so that's where we typically
start right if our problem is small when
we almost always try and start with our
problems with small we're going to be
working here we're going to be writing
what we call serial programs on one on
one computer and then the great thing
about
memory is that it you know even as our
request size gets its it's larger there
there's really not gonna do anything
better than just having the data in
memory so we'll be able to grow that
model up to datasets that aren't that
are that are fairly small maybe
gigabytes and and we can continue to use
that model just fine and then if we
decide well we're really moving beyond
that we need to do more data we can we
can go to a parallel program to get to
get more memory or we can use data in
files we can write our data to files we
can read them in and process them and
read them out and that model works very
very well and in fact particularly if
we're gonna be accessing the data in
large chunks if I have a lot of data and
look I want to do some processing on the
whole whole bit whole piece of it
likewise if we go to very large datasets
we find that we can even do parallel
programs writing files in parallel if we
want to do extremely large problems that
we want to traverse all the data but
finally we're going to come back to this
case where we need a database a database
is when we have very large amounts of
data but we want to access you know
database data that won't fit in our
memory but we want to access in little
bits we want to look up something and
that's really the only time we really
need a database unless of course someone
says this is your data it is available
to you on a database that's the only way
you're gonna access it so but if you
have control you so you always want to
follow this path you want to start with
your serial program in memory maybe go
to a parallel program using files may be
parallel files and then the let the
database is almost the tool of last
resort because it adds a great deal of
complexity and while it can look up
things much quicker if you actually end
up doing something where you're going to
be traversing a significant fraction of
the data you will find it's actually
significantly slower than if you had the
data on files so we're gonna show you
techniques we're going to follow this
path
and hopefully by the end you'll be like
oh well yes now I know I will use a
database for these instances but I
realize that I can get most of my work
done using these other techniques that
work just fine so hopefully you're going
to be learning what we call the fast
path so if you want to get a certain
level of performance okay if you have no
training
or minimal training this is the path
that you follow you you begin using a
technology your program gets slower for
a while you beat your head against the
wall and the web for a while maybe
eventually after days you get back to
where you were and then slowly you climb
up here to getting to some level of
performance weeks later this is
something we observe time and time again
and typically what happens is that right
around here people just give up with the
technology they say the technology
didn't work for them so we're the point
of this class is to give you the
techniques that an expert would have an
expert could use the technology know
exactly how to use it
and then can go on this path where
basically within hours they're getting
good performance and if they really want
to take it to the next level they can
spend days doing that and so that's kind
of our whole philosophy here so we're
gonna actually have some new concepts in
this course I think they're talked about
in the in the of course outline a little
bit some of the really new ideas that
you probably want to have run across in
in other courses so we're gonna talking
about graphs a lot in this course um
the standard graph that how many people
have taken a graph theory course or a
computer science course that talked
about graphs see most most I'm glad to
see linear algebra is still the stronger
one here that's important
we don't between the two having the
linear algebra background is the more
important but and I can if you know
linear algebra I can teach you graph
theory pretty easily
the traditional definitions of graphs
though that are taught in most computer
science courses they tend to focus on
what we call undirected unweighted
graphs so these are our graph is a set
of vertices and edges and so what we're
saying when we say it's an undirected
unweighted graph is that all the edges
are the same between any two vertices
there's no real difference between them
either an edge exists or it doesn't it's
kind of like a 0 or a 1 and then it
doesn't really when we say you know two
vertices connected there's no
directionality of that and so that's the
the majority of graph theory and what's
taught in class sort of basically is
based on that excuse me
unfortunately when we get into the real
world unfortunately when we get into the
real world we find it I've never run
into that kind of graph in the real
world in the years I've been doing this
I've never actually you know run into
that kind of graph in fact another part
of that is they'll talk about the
distribution in fact you'll often hear
something called an air dish
reni graph which is just a random
connection and as any two vertices are
randomly connected with maybe some
probability you know and and again I've
never run into that either in the real
world so the focus of graph theory that
we have now that we have all this data
and compare the theory in the data
compare the theory of the experiment we
see that the theory is is wanting the
theory is not a good stepping stone into
the into the data and so what we see is
that the real data is it's not random
it's often what we call power law
distribution that a certain vertices are
very popular and many most vertices are
don't have a lot of connections to them
usually the edges are directed that is
those meaning you know I send fight if I
friend you it's not the same as you
friending me on Facebook or Twitter or
you twit face or whatever the whatever
the technology is of the future
usually the edge itself has meaning has
weight that weight could be a value it
could be words it could be other types
of things
ah the you can have typically you have
multiple edges I could send you many
friend requests you know that's not the
same thing as me sending you one friend
request maybe I can't send your friend
requests I have multiple in one friend
forever cuz I don't know but but but you
can have multiple edges between vertices
and probably most importantly is edges
are often what we call hyper and this is
very important concept that is not
there's almost never touched on in graph
theory which is that an edge can connect
multiple vertices at the same time a
classic example would be an email that
you send to multiple people in fact most
emails these days have more than one
recipient and so there is a me sending
an email to everyone in the class one
email terminan class is a hyper edge
that edge the email connects and has
direction you know me with all the
recipients that's very different than me
individually sending an email to every
single one of you which would be a
standard edge so this is an important
concept not typically discussed a lot in
standard graph theory that's very
important so we're going to move beyond
the sort of standard definition of
graphs in this class and that's going to
be hard um we're gonna deal with a
bigger definition of linear algebra
traditional linear algebra is dealing
with matrices that have indices for the
rows and the columns and the values are
real numbers may be integers may be
complex numbers we we deal with complex
numbers here a lot but we're gonna be
dealing with things like strings we're
gonna be taking linear algebra and
applying it to things like words and so
that's gonna be different and that's
actually one of my favorite maybe it
might be the part of the course it puts
you all asleep but it's actually one of
my favorite parts of the course and then
bigger definition of processing one of
the dominant things you'll hear about in
this space there's a lot of technologies
out there
popular technology is called Hadoop and
it's MapReduce parallel programming
paradigm which is a great technology to
kind of get people started but but for
people with the mathematical
sophistication that we have we can use
programming models that are that are
simply better if you understand
mathematics to the level that we do we
can give you tools for programming
parallel computers that are just more
efficient in terms of you write less
code and you get better performance than
using techniques that really are
designed for people that don't have the
mathematical the linear algebraic
background that you have so this is
really going to be the foundation of the
course so let me continue here with the
course outline so this is going to be
essentially the nine lectures of the
course I think this is still pretty
accurate so we're in the introductory
course room and review the course and
goals the next course is really going to
be dealing with this concept of
associative arrays which is the core
technology that sort of brings all this
together when I talk about extending
linear algebra to words using funny
using sorry fine using fuzzy algebra
that's really gets into mathematical
abstract algebraic concepts called group
theory it's not nearly as scary as it
may sound we'll get into that it's
actually I think quite elegant and
really good to know good to know that
when you work with the technology and
you work with associative race we've
actually thought about the mathematics
of how these things work together and
when we add a feature it's usually
because it fits mathematically and when
we don't add a feature it's usually
because someone has made a pressing like
yeah that's really going to take people
into a bad place um then we're going to
get into really sort of the sort of the
center part of the class where we're
going to show you how we do analysis of
any zone unstructured data and then
doing analysis on structured data we're
gonna I've talked about power laws we're
gonna have a whole class on power law
data modeling and that deal with them we
have another class on cross correlation
and then we're really going to get into
parallel processing in databases and
last two classes aren't even going to
merely be lectures they're going to be
really just the demos
really because that's where we're gonna
be really bringing a lot of things
together and I'm gonna walk you through
code examples but we're gonna need to
take some time to really walk you
through them because you're gonna see
wow there's all these ideas that we've
talked about coming together in these
code examples so there is we have
lectures if you see in the software
that's available in your ela grid
accounts all the lectures are there
already and I think we have lectures 1
through 7 so 7 is the 8th lecture I'm
sorry 0 through 7 so 7 is the 8th
lecture and then and that will be kind
of a short lecture and then 9 you know
that the 9th lecture will be just going
through examples so we believe in this
whole velocity philosophy of taking a
linear algebraic point of view from with
graphs so much that we even wrote a book
about it so and you've all been given
copies of this book this really gives
you kind of the the philosophy and the
power of if you think about graphs using
the tinks I highly encourage you to flip
through it there are certain parts of
this certain sections here that are
really almost taken directly out of this
book and but a lot of it is a
supplementary material and which you'll
discover is that this course is really
the bridge to these techniques this
course allows you to go from kind of
this mess of unstructured words and
other types of things and then put them
into this nice linear algebraic format
so that now you can do you know these
these techniques that are describing in
the book so so this is almost a bridge
to that and I you know I certainly
encourage you to to look at that and in
to ask me questions about it at any time
so now I'm going to come back to our
regional example which was this cyber
thing and kind of walk through that a
little bit more detail and maybe
highlight a few of the things that I've
talked about already so here's a very
standard data processing pipeline so we
want to do is we have raw data
this case our Ross cyber data which is a
series of records and we need to convert
that into a set of vertices and edge
list from which we can then do get
graphs and graphs analysis and as you'll
see typically what you do is you write
parsers to convert this data from some
RAW format to some format that is sort
of the next step in your processing
chain and then we convert these edge
lists into adjacency matrices which is
how we we we view our graphs one word on
adjacency matrix let me go back here
this is a graph for those of you don't
know the set of vertices and edges okay
and this is an adjacency matrix of that
graph basically every single row is a
vertex every single column is a vertex
and if an edge exists we put a dot here
there's a formal duality between graph
theory the fundamental operation of
graph theory is what's called
breadth-first search which is shown here
giving a starting vertex you know
traverse its edges to its neighbors and
we have the same thing going on here
given a starting vertex in a vector we
do a matrix multiply to identify the
neighbors and so at the deepest most
fundamental level graph theory in linear
algebra were linked because the
fundamental operation of graph theory is
breadth-first search in the fundamental
operation of linear algebra is vector
matrix multiply so we are wish to form
these adjacency matrices so we can take
advantage of that here's a little bit
more detail of how we're gonna use this
technology d4m to do that to have a raw
data we convert the raw data into CSV
file stands for comma separated value
files let's go to the default format of
spreadsheets and tables it's become very
popular over the years remember first
came out 20 or 30 years ago it wasn't
that popular you know it's like people
did but now it's become extraordinarily
popular
file-format it really is ideally suited
for this kind of data so we convert that
into CSV files we then take those CSV
files read them in using our d4m
technology to insert them into a
distributed database we can then query
that distributed database to get these
associative arrays and then we can from
the associate raise now we have the full
power to do our graph algorithms so d4m
really helps you in going you know these
few steps and setting the table so that
you can then do graph algorithms and you
can even then do the graph algorithms
without even using deform at all you can
just use regular linear algebraic
operations in MATLAB just fine but this
is that bridge that connector in fact I
highly recommend people do that I highly
recommend you use deform for the only
the parts of your problem that that it
is good for and uses other technologies
you know like MATLAB ordinary matrices
and other types of things it's good for
you you'll get better performance it's
good for me because if you have problems
you'll bother somebody else and not us
so that's good it's good for everybody
it's an example of kind of what this
looks like here's a proxy log that we
got from from the data shows a web you
know essentially a web a web log the
first thing we do is essentially convert
this into a CSV file so basically each
essentially entry here gets a column we
have an ID for the for the actual entry
in this case it's a source IP a server
IP a timestamp and then the actual line
of text that's associated with with it
and this can go on and on and on we can
have many different types here and and
if you were doing standard database
person put your SQL hack which is sort
of the standard database on you would
just take that data and you would make a
table that would have these columns and
you would insert them in a way you would
go okay but what we discover is that
the challenge becomes when you want to
look up data quickly or you want to
insert data let's even enormous volume
of data that you want to insert and you
want to be able to look up any say IP
address or any timestamp or something
like that
what you discover is that you know SQL
might give you good performance but
there are databases out there and
technologies that will give you better
performance and these databases are
called triple stores because they store
all the data as anyone triples yes they
store all the data as triples so which
means we will have a row and a column
and a value associated with everything
so what we do is we take our dense data
and we do what we call create an
exploded table so essentially we have
the log ID let me append that and we
take the the column name and we append
its value to it and server IP this we
call an exploded table now if you're an
old SQL person like me this this scheme
will immediately give you hive is
another type of allergic reactions and
you won't want to go to the hospital
because you're creating an enormous
number of columns and in in in in SQL
you can dynamically create columns but
at your peril that's basically you can
create columns dynamically but the
database reserves the right to recopy
the entire table and reformat the entire
table if it so requires well triple
stores don't have this requirement
triple stores only store the non-empty
non blank entries and so they're
perfectly happy with as many columns as
you want you have a billion rows and
billion columns completely fine with
that so that's a powerful thing so I
think we talked about that so we use the
indices as rows and we create unique
type value pairs for every single column
now by itself this schema does you
absolutely no good you've basically just
made your life harder because by itself
all most database tables database
systems including triple stores are
gonna have an orientation they're gonna
be row aren't it or column oriented and
in this case the databases we will be
talking about are almost always row
oriented which means they can get a row
in constant time give it a row key like
this you know you can look it up very
quickly and will give it back to you
very quickly that's what the design to
do and you can insert enormous volumes
of data and they will cyst they will be
able preserve that contract you can be
inserting millions of entries per second
and you can still look up stuff in in
milliseconds so very powerful technology
but all we've done so far has made it so
that the format of of my data is in this
funny format coming out the other side
I've just made myself harder my mother
harder
well we there is a payoff which is we
also store the transpose of the table so
anybody is used to sparse linear algebra
this is an old and ancient technique we
almost always store a and a transpose
because in sparse linear algebra will
either have a a rope oriented or column
based store and and then we just want to
keep one around because certain
operations are going to be faster with
the transpose and certain operations are
going to be faster with the matrix we do
the exact same thing here and combined
with our exploded schema now every
single one of those columns is a row and
now we have indexed every single string
in the entire database once with one
simple schema of two tables and not to
say that you know all your databases
will only have two tables but they might
be three tables or four tables is
typically what we see which is a huge
reduction compared to the standard
database schemas that one uses or
it's easy to have dozens and dozens of
tables even hundreds of tables in a sort
of well-thought-out schema here
essentially it's one schema to rule them
all one table and it's pair and you've
indexed every single thing the cost is
you've doubled your storage and every
single database person that you talked
if I set in exchange for doubling your
storage I will give you fast index
access to every single string in your
database they'll usually take that deal
a hundred times out of 100 so that's the
power here of this technology is you can
reference enormous data sets and we will
come back to this scheme over and over
again but that's sort of the madness
will be as we move forward with
associative arrays we always view things
in this way and I want you know at the
end there's a really good reason why we
do that so now we've ingested our data
into the database and we can do queries
so if I have a binding to a table and
one of the things in the deform
technology that we do that's very nice
for you is if you're using a table and
it's transpose we hide that for you
completely if you do an insert into the
table they will automatically insert as
transpose and if you do a lookup on rows
it will know to use one table if it
doesn't look up on columns it will know
to use the other table so here we're
doing essentially a range query this
just says give me all the data from this
range you know timestamp May whatever -
it looks like about a three hour time
window so that's a query into the
database and it returns an associative
array of keys and here's what that looks
like it looks like a bunch of triples
I'm going to then take two the rows of
those keys so basically I found every
single row within a particular timestamp
I now want to get the whole row so I can
get the row of that and pass that back
in the table to get the actual data now
you see I get the whole row so I get the
server IP and all that stuff the
complete list
now I'm gonna do a little algebra here I
want to create the graph it's all source
IPS and server IPS so I get to do this
with this basically correlation here
which is essentially a matrix-matrix
multiply that's it I've just constructed
the entire source IP and server IP graph
from all the data in this time window
that is the power of D for M is allows
you to do correlations on this kind of
data same way we do correlations and
using traditional techniques in linear
algebra and you can be like well wow
this year yeah I just
this is motivational at this point we'll
get into exactly how you do this in
exactly how you how this works in the
example but this is really what people
use D for M for is to get to this point
where they can do these types of
manipulations and the key to detection
theory is doing correlation this
correlations allow us to determine what
the backgrounds of our data are with
what the clutter of our data are and
then we can on our way with traditional
detection theory and signal processing
techniques and all the things that we
know we love so this is kind of that
that connection made manifest and sira
here you can see we now have an
associative array or an adjacency matrix
that's a so you know essentially the
central source IPS and their server IDs
actually plot that and that's how we got
I get the adjacency matrix of this graph
G this is what it is that's how we
constructed this is the code we actually
use to construct that graph so moving on
here so this just shows the kind of the
whole thing here we had a whole week's
worth of proxy data this just shows you
the timing that it took about two hours
to ingest it and about three hours to do
this processing you know 100 million
proxy logs 44.5 billion triples this is
big data you know this is really this is
big data this is the kind of thing that
you can do you know whatever anybody
else is doing you should be able to do
it on
your skills than other people using this
technology so that brings us to the end
of the lecture so just to summarize you
know Big Data this type is found in wide
range of areas you know document analyst
computer networks in a sequencing
there's a kind of a gap between the
tools that people traditionally use to
do this problem in d4m this technology
fills this gap so with that are there
any questions before we get on to the
examples slide yes yes so the data so so
we yes the question was does it
generalize to multi dimensions I guess
and so there may be kind of two
questions there so if you had if I just
correlated all the data it took took
that table out and just fully correlated
with I would end up with a giant matrix
of blocks each one representing
different correlations so the source IP
server IP correlation the source IP
source IP correlation which would be
empty because it's a bipartite graph and
then all the other correlations would
perform different blocks in that type of
thing so in that sense we support multi
dimensions whether we support but
supporting multi dimensions in terms of
tensors okay well generally in sparse
linear algebra there's very minimal
support for higher dimensions I'll put a
little shout-out to my friend Tammy
called-out who serve as a technology
called the sparse tensor toolbox she's a
scientist at Sandia and so I encourage
you to do that but all of our stuff is
in two dimensions from a linear
algebraic perspective also linear
algebraically the math there is a little
bit more common than when you get into
the tensor and then you have these kind
of weird products that you're starting
which you can define but are just not
common
we thought so I mean might be like well
you're really losing something there I
really like to have multiple multiple
dimensions well when we've looked at it
the fact of the matter is the sparsity
always increases as you go to higher
dimensions and the sparsity is sparse
enough so typically the kinds of data
that we will have if you have n vertices
you'll have maybe 10 times and edges so
the sparsity is you know is extremely
low we added a dimension the sort of
internal data structure cost associated
with adding that dimension would not
reap the benefits because now you're
dispersity is even lower and so that's
generally not something that is as
commonly used but if you're interesting
exploring that I certainly encourage
people to download that toolbox very
well-written software and people can
people other questions that was an
outstanding question any other questions
at this time
very good all right well why don't we
stop the recording right now and then we
will switch to go when we take like a
five-minute break I think there's some
water out there and stuff for people and
then we'll get back to ya the examples
which probably will be a lot more fun
so hopefully wake you up after after
this this is view graphs